no hay un rincón de orihiff que haya
quedado a salvo de los ataques de las
fuerzas rusas esto incluye la sede del
gobierno local donde sigue operando un
centro de distribución de ayuda
humanitaria
los pocos pobladores que no se han
marchado de la ciudad Se acercan a
recoger provisiones necesarias para
sobrevivir
Constantino asegura que han terminado
por acostumbrarse a esta nueva situación
ellos destruyen y nosotros reconstruimos
esto sucede todo el tiempo hay gente que
ha tenido la casa destruida cinco veces
muchas veces las tenemos que cubrir con
los plásticos de las carpas humanitarias
porque es imposible arreglarlas por
completo desde el comienzo de la
invasión la línea de frente quedó a
menos de cuatro kilómetros de origen
entonces las fuerzas rusas avanzaron
hasta tomar el control de la mitad de la
provincia de saporilla
es uno de los soldados responsables de
defender el espacio aéreo en la región
su audacia para derribar aviones 6 hasta
el momento que ha valido el titulado De
héroe de Ucrania a pesar de tener solo
19 años
trabajaríamos mejor con armas adecuadas
Por ejemplo yo uso un sistema de defensa
portátil de defensa aérea de fabricación
soviético que eran comunes en la década
de los 70 y 80 Así que hay desventajas
porque no son precisos
los ataques con artillería han
disminuido pero los rusos ahora azotan
la ciudad con bombas más potentes este
es el caso de este colegio destruido A
mediados de abril muchos creen que esta
es una respuesta anticipada de Rusia a
la contraofensiva que planea Ucrania en
las próximas semanas para retomar
territorios ocupados
todo puede pasar en cualquier momento
ayer Fue increíble todo de repente
estaba bajo fuego detrás de ese edificio
hubo una gran columna de humo
Lua trabaja en el centro de
invencibilidad un refugio donde se da
apoyo a la población
la gran esperanza de todos está puesta
en la contraofensiva ucraniana que
esperan que les traiga nuevamente la
calma Aunque por el momento ni ella ni
el resto de la población sabe cuándo
comenzará